300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah subhanahu wa tala's book like
you've never had before assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are wearing charlotte so i came across
this video and i found it so shocking
i'm going to get straight into inshallah
so this is a man an elderly man who's
also a co-nurse
i don't know if he's mentally stable or
not but what they do to me is absolutely
disgusting let's watch the video and
we're going to learn a very important
lesson an ayah from the quran that this
person
mentions of a real story that happened
at the time when the quran was revealed
and he alters the same thing
we'll be back
foreign
foreign
okay
[Music]
do you guys remember what he said to him
he said do it say allah to my dog yeah i
believe he's a dog himself he said i'd
say allah to my dog and he's saying look
at the man that man who might be seen
unstable because he does something you
know some things a bit strange but he's
been bullied so he's telling him to say
allah to my dog that man who you would
say okay he's not uh mutual maybe he's
crazy or he's acting like that or
whatever it may be
he is more got more accurate than these
dogs why because these sayings say allah
affair to my dog and the man goes you
know that is sinful against me and you
well to him no because he's being
coerced yeah okay but still he says it's
sinful he's telling the the the one
who's supposed to be you know the one
recording telling him come to your mind
this is wrong and what does allah
subhanahu tala say in sword and kabuto
check this out guys and i find this very
profound because it personally happened
to me in my family where a person said
the same thing he allah says allah
certainly knows those who believe and
and he will certainly know the
hypocrites and what the following verse
says those who disbelieve say to those
who believe follow our way and we will
bear the burden of the sins and the
basically saying
do what we're doing shirk and all this
kind of stuff we'll bear your sins
they're mocking we'll bear your sins
okay
and allah subhanahu ta'ala says and they
are not able to bear their burden of
their sins in the least indeed they are
pure lies they should certainly bear the
lord bear their own lords and some other
lords along with their own lords and
they will be certainly be questioned
about what they used to forge brothers
and sisters
once a family member said this to me do
this i said no
he said do it i'll bear your sins and i
was like wow when i heard that i was
like subhanallah what allah said it
increased my iman i was like the stuff
that you're uttering is in the quran
allah talks about people like you yeah
and this is a statement of cover for
akbar to come and say obey your sins
basically you're denying the the day
would you embarrass yourself what the
hell are you talking about referring to
the disbelievers
number two you are bullying the man
you're bullying the man
brothers and sisters we ask allah
protect us from these vile statements
and under their judgment every soul
that's been wrong is going to get their
right this person who has wronged them
he will get this elderly man will get
his good deeds if he has no good deeds
he will bear his burdens till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi